hello everyone and welcome to math
simplified
i'm dr umar malik and today we will be
talking about
the signs and symptoms that you can
develop if you have a heart disease
these signs and symptoms can help you to
find out the problem in early stages
and prevent further complications our
heart pumps
blood non-stop 24 7 throughout our lives
every organ depends on the heart to
deliver fresh oxygenated blood to them
that's a lot of activity and pressure so
wear and tear is bound to happen and
certain activities can cause the heart
to face problems at some point or the
other
in this video we will not talk about
specific problems themselves
but take a look at what signs and
symptoms these problems might present
with
this will help you to be more vigilant
regarding heart diseases and
identify them early on in your life so
keeping that in mind
let's start with a simple question what
is a heart disease
heart disease are one of the leading
health risks
humanity faces today according to the
american heart association
more than one in three adults suffer
from heart diseases
and according to who around 18 million
people die
each year from heart diseases which is
an estimated 31 percent of all deaths
worldwide
here we must clarify one thing heart
disease is an umbrella term
it includes diseases such as heart
failure
coronary artery disease arrhythmias
angina
atherosclerosis and other heart related
infections
irregularities and birth defects
now keeping in mind that the heart plays
a very crucial role in our survival
it may seem that something so serious
should have warning signs
but that is not the case according to
the center of disease control cdc
50 of people who die from coronary heart
disease
didn't even knew they had it because of
lack of symptoms
it is possible to develop heart diseases
without knowing it
as you go about your daily life so
it's important to know the early signs
and symptoms of heart disease
as well as the risk factors so that you
can get treatment
early and prevent more serious heart
problems
let's first talk about what are the risk
factors for developing heart diseases
according to the center of disease
control and prevention
nearly half of all the americans both
men and women
have three or more risk factors for
heart disease
let's take a look at few of these risk
factors
so that you can modify and control them
if possible
number one age growing older increases
your risk of damaged and narrowed
arteries and weakens your heart muscles
number two gender men are generally
at a greater risk of developing heart
disease
the risk for women increases after
menopause
number three a family history of heart
disease increases your risk of coronary
artery disease
especially if your parent developed it
at an early stage
number four smoking smoking is a very
important and modifiable risk factor for
heart disease
nicotine tightens your blood vessels and
carbon monoxide present in the cigarette
smoke
can damage their inner lining making
them more susceptible to atherosclerosis
heart attacks are also more common in
smokers than in non-smokers
number 5 poor diet is also a risk factor
a diet that is high in fat salt
sugar and cholesterol can contribute to
the development of heart diseases
number six uncontrolled high blood
pressure can result in hardening and
thickening of your arteries
which leads to narrowing of vessels
through which the blood flows
number seven high levels of cholesterol
in your blood can increase the risk of
plaque formation and atherosclerosis in
the blood vessels of your heart
number eight if you have diabetes this
also increases your risk of developing
heart diseases
both conditions share similar risk
factors such as obesity and high blood
pressure
obesity is also a risk factor excess
weight
typically worsens other heart diseases
and also increases the risk of
developing atherosclerosis
number 10 physical inactivity and lack
of exercise
are also associated with many forms of
heart disease
number 11 excessive stress is also a
known risk factor
a combination of risk factors may also
signal impending heart disease
for example your risk of heart disease
significantly increases if you have
diabetes
and high blood pressure now let's look
at the early signs
of heart disease usually there are no
signs of heart disease
it often presents unexpectedly in the
form of a heart attack
or other serious event but there are few
important signs and symptoms that can
help you to recognize heart problems
before they become serious in the early
stages
symptoms can develop that seem like mere
annoyances
and may come and go for example you may
have
a very short episode of heart arrhythmia
which is basically
an irregular heartbeat you can
experience
difficulty in catching your breath after
moderate physical exertion like
walking up a flight of stairs you can
develop a sense of discomfort or
squeezing in your chest
that lasts for 30 minutes to a few hours
unexplained pain in your upper torso
neck
and jaw is another early symptom
a heartbeat that is faster slower or
irregular than usual can also be the
presenting symptom
you can also experience an episode of
dizziness or fainting
heart diseases that involve your blood
vessels
are often signaled by chest pain also
known as angina
shortness of breath extreme fatigue
irregular heartbeat
and you can also experience symptoms in
your hands and feet such as
tingling numbness coldness and weakness
these symptoms can be signs that your
blood vessels have narrowed
this narrowing which can be caused by
plaque buildup
makes it more difficult for your heart
to circulate oxygenated blood
throughout your body similarly heart
diseases caused by an infection of the
heart can include symptoms
like fever shortness of breath weakness
or fatigue swelling in your legs or
abdomen
changes in your heart rhythm dry or
persistent cough
skin rashes or unusual spots
now let's discuss about some signs of a
heart attack
a myocardial infarction also known as
heart attack occurs when the heart
disease has reached at a point where
blood
flow to the muscles of the heart
decreases it becomes
so low that the heart is unable to meet
the energy demands of the muscles of the
heart itself
the most common sign of a heart attack
is just discomfort that
includes tight squeezing intense
pressure on your chest
which may or may not be associated with
chest pain
this discomfort may also be present in
your arms
back neck abdomen or jaw
during a heart attack you may also have
shortness of breath profuse sweating for
no apparent reason
nausea and lightheadedness
knowing the signs of a heart attack is
one of the most important things you can
do to safeguard your cardiac health
your ability to recover from one of
these serious events
depends on how quickly you receive
treatment for them
it can be difficult to determine if you
are experienced symptoms of a heart
attack
never ignore symptoms as normal always
seek immediate medical attention if you
are concerned about
any symptoms that you have it's crucial
to reduce your risk factors for heart
disease
whether you have symptoms or not
schedule
regular checkups even if you think you
are in excellent health
establishing a baseline for your health
will help you
and your doctor address any concerns
that arise in the future
reducing risk factors and modifying your
life habits
go a long way in decreasing your risk of
suffering from heart diseases
and also lessens the impact if you
already have one
so friends with this we come to the end
of this video
we talked about the various scientists
risk factors for heart diseases
this is a series of videos about signs
and symptoms of various diseases of our
body
comment in the section below and tell us
what topics
you would like us to cover next we at
math simplified are committed to
bringing you the latest and updated
content
if you like what we do support us by
sharing this video with someone whom
you might think find it useful you can
also become a member of a youtube
channel or support us through patreon
the links are in the description below
thank you so much for watching
and stay safe